hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
better late than never President Biden
flies into cop 27 after missing the
other world leaders because of the U.S
elections
just stop oil activist pulls their M25
protests after days of widespread
disruption and arrests on the major
Motorway
plus we evaluate the risk of coastal
erosion and rising sea levels to
communities across the UK
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and interrogate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now perhaps he had a decent
excuse for not being at cop27 for the
world leaders day given the midterm
elections in the U.S but Joe Biden has
finally flown into charmel Shake today
and much of what will be achieved at the
summit depends on what the big polluting
Nations have to offer and the US is of
course the world's second biggest
polluter after China well here's what
the president had to say when he
addressed delegates at this Gathering we
must renew and raise our climate
Ambitions the United States has acted
everyone has to act it's a duty and
responsibility of Global Leadership
countries that are in a position to help
should be supporting developing
countries so they can make decisive
climate decisions
facilitating their energy transitions
building a path to prosperity and
compatible with our climate imperative
if countries can Finance coal in
developing countries there's no reason
why we can't finance Clean Energy in
development companies
I'm pleased to announce today alongside
the European Union in Germany a 500
million dollar package to finance and
facilitate Egypt's transition to clean
energy
this package will enable Egypt to deploy
10 gigawatts of renewable energy by 2030
while bringing offline five gigawatts of
inefficient gas powered facilities
reducing emissions in Egypt and power
sector by 10 percent
we also will also work with Egypt to
capture nearly 14 billion cubic meters
of natural gas which even currently
flares vents or leaks from its oil and
gas operations
and because of this cooperation Egypt
has elevated its climate ambition and
submitting enhanced National
determination contributions
if we're going to win this fight
every major emitter Nation needs to
align with a 1.5 degrees we can no
longer plead ignorance
to the consequences of our actions or
continue to repeat our mistakes
everyone has to keep accelerating
efforts throughout this decisive decade
well let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news now and just
stop oil have suspended their protests
on the M25 after causing days of
widespread disruption on the major
Motorway that was circling London now
their supporters have been climbing
overhead gantries in several locations
forcing the police to close sections of
the road for safety while officers
remove activists now the groups say
they're putting the campaign on hold to
give the government time to consider
their responsibilities
now the European Union has agreed to a
law to expand its forests marshes and
other sinks that absorb carbon dioxide
it's a measure that could allow the
block to increase its Target for cutting
net emissions of greenhouse gases now
currently EU countries have to ensure
they compensate emissions from land use
and Forestry with at least an equivalent
amount of carbon removal and under new
law removals of CO2 will need to exceed
emissions from 2026.
Scotland and Northern Ireland have
experienced their warmest November night
on record that's according to the Met
Office provisional figures of course now
average November minimum temperatures
are around three to four degrees Celsius
at this time of year but current
temperatures are well over 10 degrees
warmer than they should be
now move or face falling into the sea
that's a dilemma which could soon face
residents of some of the UK's Coastal
communities as rising sea levels cause
Coastal erosion to accelerate across the
country now experts warn that by 2050
more than 200 000 properties around the
UK's Coastline will be at risk
potentially creating thousands of
climate refugees our science
correspondent Thomas Moore reports
the Sandy Cliffs of Norfolk are a feeble
defense against climate change sea
levels are rising speeding up natural
erosion and the village of hayesboro has
lost 40 houses in just three decades
I've lived here nearly 20 years now when
Nicola's family bought their house they
were told it would be safe for 150 years
but the sea has advanced so fast she
fears it could be gone in 10 if she's
lucky when the Seas hitting the cliff
you can the house trembles you know you
can that's how close I am now that it's
the strength of the sea you wouldn't
believe
how it can just destroy and it's just
mud and Clay here we just it's just
constantly chomping away every time we
have a high tide sea levels around the
UK have already risen by 16 centimeters
in the last 20 years but the pace is
picking up by 2050 they're predicted to
rise by 35 centimeters and by the end of
the century they're likely to have risen
by well over a meter but even that could
be an underestimate the sea will rise
much further much faster if the vast ice
sheets that blanket the polar regions
start to crumble and melt even more
rapidly scientists believe we're
approaching that Tipping Point and if it
starts it can't be stopped
hayesboro is going over the edge now but
by 2050 200 000 properties will be at
risk and the government says it's too
expensive to defend the whole Coastline
experts warn home owners aren't being
told whether they're vulnerable what
we're seeing is that the price of
coastal property Cliff top property
property at risk of flooding is not
reflecting the um the risk to which
people are exposed there needs to be
really a much more in the way of an
honest conversation around what the
future holds for Coastal communities in
hayesboro the council has helped some
people relocate but families are losing
everything and there's still no National
plan for the climate refugees we need to
get to a point where we have options so
we can't we aren't just walking in
saying I'm sorry no your property is now
time to be demolished because it's going
to be lost over less the problem is is
how do you afford the land how do you
afford the rebuild costs these are all
things that we need to explore the
government says sea levels are a natural
process so there's no compensation for
house owners but it is considering
Financial schemes and other services to
help people move in land for now though
places like hayesboro are on the road to
nowhere
Thomas More Sky News in Norfolk
okay time now for a look ahead to this
weekend's climate Show with Tom Pete Tom
is here now great to have you in the
studio together
tell us a little bit about what's coming
up this weekend I know you're looking at
deforestation in the Amazon no list yeah
we're dwelling a bit in the trees this
week we've have got a fantastic film
from uh from the Amazon by one of Skye's
great reporter Stuart Ramsey he's spent
quite a while there and I should say
this isn't just about you know trees and
animals it's about the people it's about
the people being affected be they with a
small scale Farmers some of those
incomers but they've been there for a
while and they find very responsibly
they feel they're being pushed out in
effect bullied by some of the bigger
Agricultural and also gold prospecting
interests and also some of the
indigenous indigenous groups as well
who've seen so much of their land taken
away but we're not just in the Amazon
we're also having a little look at the
global picture because there are some
countries the role that are actually
seeing an increase in forestry increase
in Forest cover China India Algeria
Poland even to a small extent the UK we
should be going a lot faster to meet our
targets but it is actually increasing
here so that yeah a lot of a lot of
Woody time on the program as well great
stuff Tom and uh talk to me about
meaningful ranks it feels like we've had
a lot lately but is that enough well I
don't know if this is a private
Obsession of mine all throughout the
summer but people like me and and the
Met Office kept talking about this
phrase meaningful rain which always felt
was quite funny because it sounded
rather sort of philosophical about the
raindrops but it's really about whether
there is enough water to begin to
recharge the storage be that reservoirs
or groundwater and therefore will we see
droughts next year and the answer is yes
as you say it has been very wet of late
particularly actually in the Southeast
where it is needed so that is good but
we're never going to be able to say if
it has full meaning until towards the
end of the winter maybe February March
time okay Tom thank you very much for
that and just a reminder that you can
watch Tom's show on Saturdays and
Sundays at 3 30 see in the afternoon or
at 7 30 in the evening
and of course we'd love more questions
from you and you can scan the QR code
here or go to any of our social media
accounts and put your questions in the
comments and Tom will answer some of
your questions in his show
well that's all for today and for this
week we'll be back on Monday and we'll
keep you updated on just what's
happening at cop27 bye
[Music]